comedians are usually known for their
best bits but Chris Farley was so much
more than just a fat guy in a little
coat this is the story behind the SNL
star that was taken too soon
undoubtedly one of Farley's most
hilarious bits is fat guy in a little
coat even in Tommy Boy a movie that's 90
Farley schtick it's a standout in a
moment when Richard played by David
Spade grows exasperated with the
buffoonish antics of Tommy played of
course by Chris Farley Tommy grabs
Richard's tiny Blazer puts it on and
chants bad guy in a little code
bad guy in a little girl it feels like
an organic moment even improvised but
that's probably because it came from
Farley and Spade messing around in real
life Spade said during a Reddit ask me
anything session that Farley would
frequently do the bit Spade recalled he
would say Davey turn around and I said
if this is fat guy in a little coat I'm
not turning around it's not funny
anymore and he would say no I've got a
whole new thing I'm doing and then I
turn around and it would be him in my
Levi Jacket and he would say fat guy in
a little coat don't you give up on it
actor Bob Odenkirk and Chris Farley were
quite the dynamic duo at the famed
Second City comedy theater getting a
jump on any NBC funded collaboration
Odin Kirk and Farley created for the
Chicago Stage the character of Matt
Foley the woefully ineffective
perpetually screaming motivational
speaker who tries to scare kids straight
by warning them they could wind up just
like him I am 35 years old
I am divorced and I live in a van down
by the river the name of the character
comes from a close friend to Farley's
the real Matt Foley did much better for
himself than the fictional one he and
Farley played rugby at Marquette
University together he went on to become
a priest in suburban Chicago and he led
Farley's funeral service in 1997. across
his half decade on Saturday Night Live
Chris Farley established a few recurring
characters the strangest among them was
the character Chris Farley from 1991 to
1993 Chris Farley headlined a sketch
called the Chris Farley Show a mock talk
show in which he held nervous shaky
one-on-one conversations with stoic
celebrities like Martin Scorsese and
Paul McCartney the questions weren't
very probing Farley would nervously
asked the guest if they remembered
hugely Monumental moments from their
career and you're a chain to the thing
and he couldn't get away yeah yeah I
remember yeah
that was awesome long time SNL writer
Tom Davis came up with the idea for the
Chris Farley Show and developed it with
Jim Downey they were inspired by
Farley's Behavior around the SNL offices
he'd ask them if they remembered a
famous sketch from the 70s and then
recreated for them right there by
himself Davis and Downey then submitted
the sketch's script for consideration as
a joke thinking it was too Niche to
their surprise executive producer Lauren
Michaels loved it and placed it into a
1991 episode hosted by Jeff Daniels
arguably the most famous Chris Farley
Saturday Night Live sketch was
Chippendales audition airing in 1990 the
bit found two men in a dance-off to land
the last open spot in the Chippendales
dance troupe the joke was that the guys
were played by Hollywood heartthrob and
SNL guest host Patrick Swayze and Farley
Swayze's character won but not before
Farley careened shirtless around the
stage his large stomach on display it's
the first SNL sketch where Farley had
the main role and cast mate Mike Myers
thought it was magical he said in the
documentary I am Chris Farley after the
Chippendales we were like oh those guys
this guy's gonna be giant he's gonna be
a huge star future Better Call Saul star
Bob Odenkirk was a member of the SNL
writing staff at the time and in his
2022 Memoir comedy comedy comedy drama
he discussed his distaste for
chippendale's audition then and now he
was disappointed that the sketch got so
much attention and praise I know
confirmed Chris's worst instincts about
being funny which was how he proved his
worth that getting laughed at was as
good as getting a laugh shame and
laughter are synthesized in the worst
way that sketch Farley's co-star Chris
Rock shared a similar sentiment in the
Chris Farley Show calling the sketch out
for body shaming the comic rock said
there's no comic twist to it it's just
mean
two years after his termination Chris
Farley returned to Saturday Night Live
as a guest host and it was not an easy
week for anyone Farley was supposed to
bring along a sobriety coach but he
instead showed up ready to drink
apparently the cast and crew could all
tell that Farley was in bad shape SNL
boss Lauren Michaels were called to
Rolling Stone he was not in shape the
way he had been five years earlier and
while I felt good about the show I think
he was spent by air time that episode
opened with a twisted but apparently
honest sketch in which Michaels is
concerned that Farley is too unstable to
host the show cast member Tim Meadows
reassures him claiming that Farley has
gotten better Farley then shows up and
to prove his medal introduces his
sobriety sponsor Chevy Chase another
former SNL cast member who also
struggled mightily with substance abuse
later in the show after Farley grew
visibly winded during a sketch Norm
Macdonald struck out with a weekend
update joke he brushed it off and said
now one wasn't very good but
try to laugh anyway because it helps
Farley have a little rest
that SNL episode turned out to be the
last time Farley would ever perform for
an audience
Farley was a big guy but he carried
himself on screen and on the SNL stage
with the grace of an athlete or even a
dancer that made his physical comedy and
stunt work all the more impressive it's
probably not too much of a surprise then
to learn that Young Chris Farley was an
extremely talented and accomplished
athlete he was on the heavier side as a
child and despite not having the body
one would usually associate with a
swimmer he was positively dolphin-esque
his brother Tom Farley said to Rolling
Stone Chris would get up on the blocks
as a 10 year old and kids would start
snickering at him then he'd hit the
water with those big broad shoulders of
his go into the butterfly stroke kicking
up this rooster tail and leave those
kids in the dust Chris Farley did have
the traditional build of a football
player and as a high schooler in Madison
Wisconsin he made the All-City team as a
defensive lineman he had a dream of
going pro after school but when he
graduated he realized that at five nine
and 230 pounds he probably wouldn't be
big enough to Be an Effective NFL player
beneath the humor Chris Farley often
played sensitive hurt and even broken
characters Farley also lent a boisterous
energy to almost every role he played
and when the cameras weren't rolling he
could apparently be just as wound up as
the characters on an episode of The Late
Late Show with James Corden David Spade
recalled that when the cast of Tommy Boy
arrived for filming in Toronto Farley
felt under the weather and went to bed
early so Spade went out to grab a drink
with co-star Rob Lowe Farley heard about
that innocent friend date and apparently
he was the extremely jealous type Spade
explained that Upon returning to set
Farley Snidely asked him about his
hangout with Rob Lowe the jealousy then
greatly escalated later that day Spade
recalled that during lunch Farley walked
up to him and purposefully stepped on
his hand and then I got up and threw my
diet coke on him it was straight out of
like Atlanta housewives they fought
proper fight Chris Farley was a
religious guy throughout his lifetime
raised in the Roman Catholic faith he
was educated in parochial schools
according to the bazo attending the
catholic-affiliated Marquette University
in his adult life that spirituality
manifested as a commitment to community
service Farley did a lot of Hands-On
charity work even after he ascended to
stardom as one of the most famous and
recognizable comedians on the planet
according to the documentary I am Chris
Farley in his days as a performer with
the Second City improv troupe he'd never
accept payment for charity shows saying
that his salary should go to whatever
charity the performance benefited after
he moved to New York for SNL Farley
frequently volunteered at shelters and
unhoused meal centers and he also made
visits to Pediatric Wards at local
hospitals most of his closest friends
didn't even know that Farley did all
that stuff until long after he died
Farley struggled with addictions to
drugs and alcohol and he sadly lost that
war on December 18 1997. the comedian
actor was discovered in the Chicago
apartment after reportedly going on a
four-day Bender but Farley wasn't
exactly a reckless junkie or a live fast
die young kind of guy he desperately
tried to get clean in just the last two
years of his short life Farley entered
Rehabilitation Facilities 17 times which
is to say nothing of other attempts at a
healthier life such as quitting
substances cold turkey weight loss
programs joining Alcoholics Anonymous
and Overeaters Anonymous and
interventions from friends and
co-workers Farley even checked himself
into the famous hassled and drug rehab
center in Minneapolis just before his
death but he always struggled to fully
quit for long I'm gonna die from that
buddy you gotta stop you gotta stop yeah
it's just not gonna end right and then
and there you go that commitment
extended to movie sets the last film
Farley worked on was the adventure
comedy Almost Heroes during the first
week of shooting in 1997 Farley was
drinking so much that when producers
found out they threatened to shut the
movie down that led Farley to hire a
sobriety guard who hung out with him for
the duration of the shoot making sure he
didn't ingest any illicit substances
producer Denise denove even found
Alcoholics Anonymous meetings for the
actor to attend prior to his death Chris
Farley completed his work on Almost
Heroes and had several potential movies
waiting for him but there was one other
one for which he'd almost finished his
work and it could have combined his
fantastic gifts for Comic yelling and
playing sensitive misunderstood
characters Farley had been cast in the
title role in Shrek and he'd recorded
about 85 percent of his lines production
held up for a year while the filmmakers
decided what to do even considering
employing a Farley sound alike to record
the final 15 percent of the dialogue
finally producers decided to recast and
start over with a brand new actor Mike
Myers Farley's old Saturday Night Live
cast me Meyer's interpretation of the
character which became the foundation of
a blockbuster Shrek franchise was very
different from Farley's as leaked rough
footage later showed Farley's take was
much more understated and even dramatic
than Meyer's broadly comic Scottish
accented version
Chris Farley was among the biggest
comedy stars in the world when he died
in 1997 and he was young just 33 years
old he likely had a long career in front
of him and his death brought an end to a
number of intriguing projects that could
have shown Farley was capable of a lot
more than just broad physical comedy he
had an interest in starring at a film
based on Mordecai rickler's cult
favorite humor novel The incomparable a
tuck a satire about an Inuit who leaves
Alaska for the first time and
experiences culture shock in New York
City Farley also nearly starred in a
movie version of A Confederacy of Dunces
the Pulitzer prize-winning classic novel
about an arrogant over-educated loser
living amongst colorful characters in
1960s New Orleans it's safe to say
Farley could have even scored himself
some Oscar buzz for another project he
had in the works the starring role in a
movie about old-time Hollywood star and
Scandal magnet Fatty Arbuckle with a
script written by David Mamet if if you
or anyone you know is struggling with
addiction issues help is available visit
the Substance Abuse and Mental Health
Services Administration website or
contact samhsa's National helpline at
1-800-662-help that's 1-800-662-4357
foreign